Can the rife bulb break? Can the hammer tube break?
Oh, I know. Some people have other bulbs for their rife as well.
They would probably haven't gotten those from us, because we typically recommend only the hammer bulb or whatever you want to call it but the cylindrical tube.
Can it break? Yes, it can.
So the most common way that the bulb could break is the wire could pull off of it.
So you have a electrical disconnection, but it can also break by hitting the ends.
This gets hit on a damage because the wire is then connect to the bulb, but the bulb is filled with gas and then the electricity goes, frequencies are going through that gas.
And that's the treatment phase of the bulb, and it's picked up on the other side and then carried back for the circuit.
So if you hit the ends of it or you drop the bulb and it bangs on the ground on the end, that would be the second most common way it would break because it disconnected from the glass. That's not repairable.
Typically the first way, if it's disconnected at the, how you plug it into the machine, the little thing that you plug into the machine.
Typically that can be repaired, depends on which bulb you have.
If you have the ones that we have created, those are repairable, the true right ones are typically not repairable, though I know now that we could probably repair those.
But they're not repairable from true right. So if that was an issue, we could probably fix that.
But that's very easy visually to see if that is the problem.
It's hard to see if the second most common way, if it's broken off at the bulb itself, it's hard to see if that is the issue.
And it can look completely intact. Like why is this bulb not working? It looks perfectly fine.
Now understand if something happens in your bulb is not lighted up on your right machine.
Most of the time it's not your bulb. You may have blown a fuse because most common way that one would blow a fuse is that you are accidentally running your,
your bulb program on the, the, the ARR, you'd be putting it on the AUX setting or on the true right if you'd have it on the, the, the, the bath setting.
So if you have the, the little switch in the front accidentally toggled to the AUX or on the true right toggle to the bath and you're trying to run a bulb program, you could blow a fuse.
And, and then the machine looks like it's running. It can, the program can even be counted down, but there's no light coming out of the bulb.
That's the most common reason why a bulb doesn't work. It should literally has nothing to do with the bulb. You blow a fuse on the machine.
Actually, even more common than that is that you actually have it set. You have that toggle toggled to AUX or toggle to bath and you're running a day program.
You're wondering why my light's not working. And before you blow a fuse, it just won't work. And if you just toggle it back, the light would come on.
So all these, all this information that I'm saying is in your troubleshooting guide that we do ask if something isn't working like your bulb isn't working that you do look at your troubleshooting guide.
I do please look at the frequency healing course. I have dozens and dozens of videos on the frequency healing course.
Quite two different troubleshooting as well.
But then the bulb can actually break by the bulb itself breaking. Now, that has never happened in all the years that I've been doing this.
That has never happened with the hammer bulb or the tubular bulb. It has happened with some of the other bulbs. The spiral bulb.
That's very easily breakable. That's happened multiple times. If you drop that, it's going to break.
So you sure I've used to have a double bubble bulb that was pretty thick glass. So it was hard to break that. But I have had a couple of people break that.
And then there's some other bulbs that are breakable that you could break. So it's obvious if the bulb breaks that way to know that it breaks.
But it's when it's what you can't see that is the issue. So, but yes, it is possible to break a bulb.
But make sure you go through the troubleshooting guide because if your bulb is not lighted up most commonly.
It has nothing to do with the bulb. It has something to do with either the setting you are inadvertently running it under.
However, you have to have it toggled to bulb in order for it to be working. If you toggle it to back or aux, you could blow a fuse and certainly it won't run anything out of the bulb.
So make sure you use your troubleshooting guide. Make sure you view the videos on the frequency healing course for any other troubleshooting things.